[Musique]
la police intrajournalière a procédé à une
Des patrouilles constantes à Guaremal étaient un
quartier où ils ne pouvaient pas ouvrir le
le transport n'est pas entré dans les entrepôts
public où les criminels ont imposé
un contact qui, dans la somnolence, avait déjà cela comme
parvient à être maintenant
ce problème de criminalité est mort
Oh
regarder
par ici
la particularité au sein
ces déploiements
de l’augmentation des cas et du
apparition de nouveaux
de nouvelles souches déjà
Du Brésil, nous avons aiguisé le
l'intensité du travail à venir
développer avant de le faire avec
périodes séparées environ 15 environ 15 jours
maintenant nous le faisons pratiquement
semaines
[Musique]
à utiliser, nous avons une mutation
du virus qui m'attend au moins dans
le sèche-linge silencieux et nous voulons éviter le
contagion massive des citoyens et c'est
C'est pourquoi nous ajustons le
mesures pour préserver la santé
[Musique]
arriver
Oh